um but you'll have seen the reports
about swella bravaman and whether or not
she asked civil servants to arrange this
private speed awareness course for her
what's your sort of reaction I think
Rishi sunak should launch an
investigation into it he should ask the
independent advisor whether she's
breached the standards of the
ministerial code here I think a lot of
people watching this program will think
you know why is it always one rule for
them and another rule for everybody else
but you know suela bravaman's got got
form on this hasn't she you'll remember
she actually had to resign as home
secretary under Liz truss because she
sent confidential documents to a Tory MP
when she shouldn't have done that and
Rishi sunak reappointed her as Home
Secretary why because he had to keep the
right wing of his party on board so
there's no point in him getting all
techy at the G7 press conference
it's it's because of him that she's
there so I've got my own views about
that sort of behavior but actually what
she what he should do is launch an
investigation to make sure we get to the
bottom of this and to see whether she
has actually breached the ministerial
code and I guess what Defenders of
Sorella problem might say is that there
isn't really one rule for her and one
for everyone else because she did try to
do the speed awareness course and then
in the end ended up accepting the points
on her license
but why why did she ask civil servants
you don't forget she's the Home
Secretary asking civil servants whether
there should be a different Arrangement
that the rest of us have to have for her
is that the highest standards of probity
and integrity that we should rightly see
from our ministers I don't think it is
but actually what sunak should do is
launch that investigation or have more
on the story of course
um as it develops as the day goes on
um The Wider story on when it comes to
homosexual of course is the net
migration figures we're expecting out uh
next week Richardson has been very clear
he says that he wants to bring net
migration down from the current levels
of around 500 000 he thinks it's too
high what's Labor's position is that too
high and do you want to see it come down
I expect it to come down and it should
come down and I think the real issue
here is this that in Labor's
points-based immigration system we have
to tie up
what we're seeing in terms of a skills
Gap in our population and actually put
in place the programs to deal with that
so that we don't have to have the work
visas that we're seeing at the moment I
mean just look at Health and Social care
that is the area where the highest
number of visas are being issued at the
moment but what does the government do
it cuts Medical School places this year
by three thousand denying opportunities
for bright young britons to have a
fantastic job in our NHS social care the
government we've just heard has halved
the funding it promised in its white
paper for the social care Workforce so
that is the wrong approach where we have
skill Scouts labor said we will set up
skills for England to identify where
those problems are and put in place
those proper trainings it's interesting
to talk about a health sector and in
terms of those migration figures because
as you say we do see a huge number of
people coming from abroad to work in our
house service nurses doctors care
workers
is that a problem
I think we should be doing more to make
sure we have the proper training in this
country why is that is it because it's a
risk to rely on people no no because I
think it is a fantastic career and
opportunity I look in my own sector of
social care you know care workers do
some of the most important work in this
country looking after the people we love
most our elderly and disabled relatives
I think this is a huge area of growing
demand in future we know that our
population is aging and I also think by
having properly trained and paid care
workers in every part of the country
that will make a huge contribution to
our economy too so let's Champion that
rather than undermine it tomorrow kiss
Thomas giving a speech on the NHS who's
going to say the NHS is not sustainable
unless we make serious deep long-term
changes so what are the changes what
what what's the idea so when the NHS was
created average life expectancy was 63.
now it's 80 and one in four babies born
today is set to live to 100. back then
the major cause of death and disease was
infectious diseases and accidents now
it's long-term chronic conditions like
cancer heart disease and diabetes a
quarter of us are living with two
long-term conditions or more and a third
of people who end up in a e have five
conditions or more our NHS is not set up
to deal with those problems what's the
idea the big thing is to get the shift
towards prevention early intervention
and more support in the community at
home it's about bringing together all
these separate teams into one place if
you've ever had to deal with an elderly
relative stuck in hospital you have to
battle your way around the system
ringing five six seven people what we
need is one team to help keep people up
so when you talk about prevention
one of the things the leaves the
government have is regulation so taxes
for example or on sugar more regulation
around junk food is that what labor
would do we do want to see a ban on junk
food advertising targeted at children
and young people what about taxes on
unhealthy food I think what we have seen
with the the sugar Levy is that that one
of the things the government has done is
that has made a difference so we will be
looking and you'll forgive me for not
making all the announcements today
you'll have to wait and see until the
mission tomorrow it is about Shifting
the focus towards prevention but it's
also about transforming those Services
if you're comfortable about making food
more expensive at a time when people are
really struggling to pay for food
actually I I've I've seen here in the
past when when labor was in government
that actually having a a fair regulatory
system where you are taking action on
sugar and salt in people's Foods did
make a difference but I would say to you
too here Sophie it is a about far more
than that it is about radically Shifting
the focus of services out of hospitals
and into the community joining them up
around the needs of patients and users
because that's what we need to live
longer healthier more independent I know
we'll get more details tomorrow always a
slight frustrating time I'm sure do an
interview to be completely honest with
you as a result
um now Kirsten says money's part of it
but it's not just about money but money
is a part of it as well you're talking
about social care right a big problem
the reason we've got so many vacancies
in Social care is that you can earn more
money working at supermarket so why
would you stay in Social care can I just
come back labor labor say they want a
national Care Service there's as much
ambition as the 1945 NHS
realistically is labor looking at
putting up taxes in order to fund some
of the changes no and can I just come
back to you on that point I actually
used to say the same it is true that you
can earn more working in Supermarket or
Hospital Hospitality but actually a
third of people one in three who leave
the care Workforce actually go and work
for the NHS okay so we need to joined up
a Workforce plan there but I'm talking
seriously here about money right because
you're talking about huge you're talking
about 1945 style Reformation of a
national Care Service you're talking
about chronic Staffing shortages are you
looking at potentially wealth taxes the
reason I'm asking this is back in 2021
Kirsten was asked how he would fund an
increase in Social care funding he says
those that earn their money in ways
other than work should pay their own
share people who earn their money from
properties dividend stock shares they
should be looked at so that was back in
2021 I assume you have been looking at
it are you looking at wealth taxes to
try we're not and you'll know that I'm
not going to sit here and pluck out
figures out of nowhere when goodness
knows what the state of the economy will
be by the time of the next general
election we've been pretty honest where
we do want to see increases in
investment where we'll get the money
from we've said that we'll scrap the
non-dom tax status in order to fund the
biggest Workforce expansion in the nhs's
history ten thousand more nurses
doubling the number of medical school
places five thousand more districts
that you're planning the biggest
transformation since 1945 when the NHS
was created if you're not saying that
there's going to be any more money to
fund it
but whilst extra investment is essential
what I would argue here Sophie is reform
is absolutely part of it too sure that
why have we got why have we got but we
have said where we'll increase funding
taxes yes
you may not well I don't think money
alone is the solution and if you don't
think 10 000 more nurses are doubling
the number I'm a medicine whether you
can do a reform similar to 1945 when
you're talking about you know around
five six billion pounds extra money
about reform why why does a family have
to ring six or seven different numbers
to try and get the services that their
elderly parent needs why don't we have
one team because there's one person and
they don't see their needs in separate
service silos reform can make a huge
difference if you look at delayed
discharges from hospital
1.7 billion pounds spent last year on
elderly people in hospital who didn't
need to be there imagine the difference
that could make if that was spent in the
community or at home reform alongside
investment is what we need to make the
NHS fit for the future okay thank you
very much for being on the program Liz
Kendall uh for the labor party